[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 l'essentiel de l'actualité locale en
quelques minutes voici les titres de ce
jeudi 8 juillet les congés d'été débute
une période où les gendarmes des
yvelines sont sur le pont opération de
contrôle sur les grands axes pour les
grands et les départs en vacances
vigilance sur le sujet des cambriolages
reportage lors d'une action péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines et a invité le
colonel sylvain tortelier commandant du
groupement de gendarmerie des yvelines
aigrement petite commune des yvelines
d'un peu plus de 1000 habitants est
désormais doté d'une bande de véhicules
électriques elle permet de recharger
deux voitures au même moment
l'équipement était mise en service ce
matin ce projet a été lancé en
partenariat avec les collectivités
locales et l'opérateur ses new by
numérique
et puis direction versailles à la fin de
ce journal jusqu'à la fin septembre la
tradition des guinguettes s'empare de la
ville un événement en plein air pour
faire la fête avec concerts et jeux sur
place et proposé par la municipalité
avec la collection versailles open air
et à versailles également le nouveau
palais des congrès se dévoile après deux
ans de travaux les lieux ont été
inaugurés officiellement ce matin et
c'était en présence du ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire une grande
opération de contrôle de transport
routier réalisé cette semaine dans cinq
péage franciliens dont celui de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines les agents de
la direction générale régionale inter
départementale de l'environnement de
l'aménagement et des transports ont
contrôlé poids lourds étrangers et
véhicules utilitaires légers
le reportage de julie prigent les
contrôles de transport routier
s'enchaînent au péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines c'est le
résultat d'une grande opération de
contrôles organisés mardi 6 juillet par
les directions régionales de
l'environnement de l'aménagement et des
transports d'île de france et du centre
val de loire
l'enjeu de cette journée c'est d'abord
de montrer
de donner à voir eux
par cette mobilisation très forte une
réalité du quotidien du contrôle que
nous réalisons chaque jour en bord de
route sur les aires de service sur les
quais de chargement pour assurer le
respect de la réglementation du
transport routier et la sécurité des
usagers de la route les contrôleurs
vérifient le respect des règles de temps
de conduite et de repos le dispositif de
protection de l'environnement dit à des
blue mais aujourd'hui c'est sur les
véhicules utilitaires légers qu'ils vont
s'attarder particulièrement le député
damien pichereau a rendu un rapport en
2018 qui a montré un véritable enjeu de
sécurité autour de la vétusté de ces
véhicules et de la surcharge quasi
systématique de ces véhicules
la surcharge représente d'une part un
danger pour la sécurité des usagers mais
aussi
elle pose un problème du point de vue de
la concurrence en une journée c'est une
centaine de véhicules qui vont être
vérifié ces gens nés exceptionnelle de
contrôle routier simultanée dans les
cinq grands ph d'ile-de-france ont lieu
environ trois fois par an et avant
d'accueillir mon invité pour parler
justement de sécurité routière ce
reportage avec justement des ateliers
ludiques pour sensibiliser les
vacanciers aux dangers de la route sur
une aire de l'autoroute a10 ils ont été
réalisés par des jeunes qui effectuent
leur s est nul le service national
universel
le temps d'un week-end ces jeunes
volontaires de 15 à 17 ans décidé
justement de faire de la prévention
routière juliette prigent et bixente n'a
rien senti steban ils sont dix gènes à
tenir des ateliers de prévention
routière al aire d'autoroute de limours
janvry sur l'a10 dimanche 4 juillet
le but est vraiment sensibiliser les
gens à la vigilance c'est notamment d'un
point de vue avec tout ce qui est
somnolence sur l'autoroute consommation
de substances
donc voilà on conseille pour la
somnolence aux gens de s'arrêter toutes
les deux heures de faire une pause au
moins après ou plus s'ils sont vraiment
fatiguées
donc le but est vraiment d'être ludique
et pédagogique
cette mission d'intérêt général est
organisée dans le cadre de leur s est
nul le service national universel pour
sa ces jeunes âgés de 15 à 17 ans ont
choisi le thème de la prévention
routière et tout a été organisé par
leurs soins donc ce sont les jeunes
cadets qui ont monté leur action avec
l'aide d'un certain nombre de
partenaires qui leur ont apporté d un
certain nombre d'informations et qui
ont décidé du message qu'il voulait
passer puis de la forme dans laquelle il
voulait la faire passer nous avons
besoin de sensibiliser nos clients la
sécurité routière et donc ça tombait
vraiment très bien que ces jeunes lui
assènent ils veulent s'associer à cette
opération
les dix volontaires ont choisi de
s'engager auprès des cadets de la
gendarmerie
ce qui réjouit le lieutenant colonel
nicolas le guyader le fait de s'engager
comme ça ça génère une certaine
solidarité une cohésion au sein de
l'équipe et se hisse à nu c'est vraiment
ça c'est vraiment c'est donner du temps
personnel pour les autres et en fait
c'est très très enrichissant dans le
monde de maintenant en france c'est près
de 18000 gènes qui réalisent leur
service national universel chaque année
à des routes qui vont être grandement
emprunté dans les prochains jours bison
futé voit rouge dans le sens des départs
en ile de france pour la journée de
vendredi mais celle aussi des 2 samedi
prochain période de grands départs en
vacances d'été et plus généralement ou
la gendarmerie des yvelines est
particulièrement mobilisé on en parle
avec mon invité par visioconférence le
colonel sylvain tortelier bonsoir
bonsoir à vous vous êtes le commandant
de groupement du groupement de
gendarmerie des yvelines est ce qu'on
peut dire que l'été c'est une période de
particulière vigilance pour les
gendarmes des yvelines oui c'est une
période effectivement haute vigilance en
ce qui nous concerne a singulièrement
vous venez d'évoquer effectivement le
sujet donc routiers ou autoroutiers
donc effectivement c'est un sujet donc
enfin c'est une instamment transhumance
qui nous concerne nous intéresse
directement et pour là pour laquelle
effectivement on essaie de répondre
présent sur sur ce sujet là mais aussi
sur d'autres on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'y revenir
effectivement dans cet entretien avec
sur ce sujet typiquement de la sécurité
routière de routière c'est l'escadron de
sécurité routière qui est mobilisée
c'est ça oui singulièrement c'est
l'escadron départemental de sécurité
routière qui est aux avant-postes si
j'ose dire
mais pas seulement puisque naturellement
on peut mobiliser dans l'ensemble notre
maillage des 20 unités territoriales
pour avoir une action en tout cas
offensive sur ce sujet là puisque depuis
le début de l'année malheureusement nous
déplorons quelques morts sur notre
réseau autoroutier comme notre réseau
secondaire sur ce sujet quelles sont vos
missions sur la sécurité routière
alors singulièrement dans qu'à
l'occasion des grands chassés croisés
nous allons avoir une action offensive
offensif comme je disais pour lutter
contre tout ce qui est conduites
addictives dans tout ce qui est
stupéfiant tout ce qui est alcool mais
également tout ce qui génère
traditionnellement beaucoup d'accidents
matériels corporels et mortels à savoir
donc les grands excès de vitesse et
malheureusement on observe que depuis
donc le confinement de mauvaises
habitudes ont pu être prises ici ou là
en la matière et nous aurons également
une vigilance toute particulière tournée
donc vers les usagers des deux roues
motorisés car c'est une catégorie donc
l'usagé de la route qui paye un large
tribut aux morts sur nos routes
yvelinoise en particulier depuis début
de l'année et vous parliez d'offensive
est ce que l'idée c'est aussi lors de
ces contrôles de faire toujours de la
prévention alors on accomplit que vous
m'aviez parlé de d'actions offensives
mais ce qui a toujours un rôle de
prévention tout de même oui bien sûr on
fait toujours donc nos contrôles dans un
esprit donc le discernement de fermeté
et de et d' équilibre a manifestement
donc on sait dans certaines
circonstances faire preuve de
bienveillance et dans d'autres en
revanche de fermeté lorsque la vie des
autres et manifestement mise en jeu mise
en péril bien évidemment avant qu'on
parle d'un autre sujet est-ce que vous
avez des conseils justement à donner aux
yvelinois qui s'apprête à prendre la
route en vue de ses vacances d'été
oui bah tout simplement préparez votre
déplacement préparer votre chargement
préparer votre voiture
préparez-vous entreposés vous avant
avant de prendre le volant tout
simplement
alors l'été c'est aussi une période où
il ya beaucoup de craintes concernant
les cambriolages même si leur nombre a
baissé l'an passé en france avec 185
1600 cambriolage tout de même sur le
territoire français ça c'est un vrai pot
problème aussi dans les yvelines les
télés les cambriolages c'est une
thématique sur laquelle vous êtes aussi
mobilisés ah oui c'est d'une thématique
qui nous mobilise à l'année et est
singulièrement l'été puisque l'on peut
pas re construction donc certains
occupants sont amenés à quitter leur
résidence et par la même occasion donc à
les rendre donc vulnérable d'une
certaine manière
donc nous avons des opérations qui
précisément sont destinées à les
protéger à les sécuriser c'est notamment
une opération assez ancien e
on met à disposition des propriétaires
qui quittent leur logement
c'est une opération qui scelle
l'opération tranquillité vacances donc
c'est simple d'usagé sur la consiste
donc à aller récupérer un formulaire sur
sur internet à le remplir en portant à
notre connaissance dans la période
d'absence ensuite donc il s'agit donc de
mettre à notre disposition ce formulaire
là et donc nous on rentre donc les
coordonnées donc des gens qui sont qui
sont partis dont de leur résidence dans
nos smartphone un autre téléphone de
service à charge pour nous donc plus
particulièrement de dédier de
patrouilles de surveillance sur ces
secteurs là où les propriétaires sont
partis en vacances et si malheureusement
on constate des anomalies des incidents
des tentatives ou des effractions
constitué on se met en rapport
évidemment soit avec le propriétaire
soit avec la personne de confiance qui
nous aura désigné dans le formulaire
dangereux viennent par ati est ce que
c'est une opération qui marche ça ça
dissuade cette opération ça dissuade
donc effectivement les gens qui
pourraient être intéressés par l'idée de
commettre des méfaits effectivement de
voir les patrouilles de gendarmes à
proximité donc deux secteurs
pavillonnaires ou pas seulement donc ça
évidemment ça ça dissuade de
construction et d'un autre côté donc ça
rassure également les propriétaires qui
sont absents dans leur résidence
je voulais également en profiter pour
mentionner que cette opération
tranquillité vacances vaut aussi pour
les chefs d'entreprise et les
commerçants qui peuvent nous signaler
sont les mêmes modalités
donc un commerce qui seraient vides
d'occupants particulièrement cet été et
là aussi comme les résidences
principales
nous pouvons donc préférentiellement
orienter nos patrouilles verser ces
commerces en particulier avec aussi dans
les yvelines une particularité 39 % du
territoire et agricoles il ya forcément
beaucoup d'exploitations avec aussi une
des mois sont toujours sensibles où les
agriculteurs laisse parfois dans les
champs leurs leur matériel et aussi
des actions des interventions auprès de
ses agriculteurs
oui évidemment c'est une population qui
elle ne sera probablement pas amené à
partir cet été puisqu'ils seront très
occupés notamment dans les champs alors
on a un dispositif qui s'appelle le
dispostif sms agri c'est à dire que dès
lors qu'on est confronté un phénomène
sérielle ou inquiétant qui concerne nos
agriculteurs on descend cette
information-là auprès de tous les gens
qui sont référencés auprès de nous pour
précisément les sensibiliser voire
éveiller leur attention sur je vous dis
un phénomène un véhicule ou des
comportements suspects concernant donc
des exploitations agricoles ou des
surfaces avec une dernière chose colonel
sylvain tortelier forcément l'événement
de l'été dans les yvelines c'est le tour
de france qui va passer par chat ou le
18 juillet prochain
là aussi mobilisation des gendarmes des
yvelines sur cet événement bien sûr
mobilisation que des personnels d'activé
aussi donc de réservistes puisque nous
avons mobilisé pas moins d'une trentaine
de réservistes au delà donc de la
vingtaine de militaires lanta kid active
qui seront effectivement engagé donc le
18 juillet sur cette dernière et arm
dernière étape du tour de france qui
doit rester dans une grande fête
populaire donc là aussi j'en appelle à
la vigilance de tous pour faire que
cette belle épreuve reste un mouvement
est une épreuve de fête pour tous merci
à vous que le nail sylvain tortelier
javaux a pris bonne soirée et je
rappelle que vous êtes le commandant du
groupement de gendarmerie des yvelines
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également les
propriétaires de voitures électriques
vont maintenant taper le nom daigremont
dans leur gps ce jeudi la ville vient de
se doter d'une borne électrique dernière
génération
ce projet a été lancé en partenariat
avec les collectivités locales et
notamment seine et yvelines numériques
michael et demi d'euros c'est une grande
première dans la commune dégremont la
ville a inauguré ce jeudi 8 juillet une
borne électrique
le dispositif a été lancé en partenariat
avec les collectivités locales et
notamment seine et yvelines numériques
il permettra à deux véhicules de se
recharger en simultané en deux heures
c'est bien sûr destiné aux gros montois
qui n'ont pas si vous voulez des bornes
ou en tout cas un jardin suffisamment
grand pour avoir des bornes pour
recharger les véhicules
c'est pour des habitants c'est pour des
visiteurs c'est pour aussi toute une
série de personnes qui parlent sur la
rd30 sur la nationale 113 et qui ont
besoin de recharger leurs véhicules et
qu'ils feront un petit détour une petite
boucle pour venir le faire un projet
soutenu par la plupart des 1100
habitants de la commune
personnellement je suis très content de
cette installation parce que j'ai avec
j'ai acheté ma voiture il ya deux
semaines et justement je me posais la
question de wes que je vais pour la
charger sur la commune et là ça répond
totalement à mes attentes
la ville dégremont n'est pas la seule
concernée par le projet seine et
yvelines numériques va également
installer des bornes dans six autres
commune yvelinoise cet été objectif
booster ce secteur il ya trois freins
finalement à l'acquisition de véhicules
électriques
1 le prix des véhicules électriques et
les san ou collectivités locales on n'y
peut rien de l'autonomie des véhicules
encore une fois on n'y peut pas
grand-chose et trois le nombre de points
de recharge et là c'est là qu'on a nous
collectivités locales un rôle à jouer
pour faciliter et faire tomber cette
barrière du nombre de points de recharge
si le projet concluant sur ces communes
l'objectif sera de proposer dès 2022 des
offres pour accompagner le développement
de l'électromobilité dans l'ensemble des
yvelines
lors de son inauguration en 1967 il
était le tout premier bâtiment du genre
en france le palais des congrès des
verts sz de versailles a connu ces deux
dernières années une rénovation pour
l'intérieur pour le rendre plus
accessible plus lumineux
un nouveau site inauguré ce matin en
présence du ministre de l'économie bruno
le maire sur place mélanie poker une
nouvelle scénographie un écran géant 4k
une salle de 1000 places
le palais des congrès de versailles
souhaite reprendre vie les travaux ont
regardé le style architectural pensé par
pierre edouard lambert la ville il ya
investi 4 millions d'euros le nouveau
gestionnaire 2 millions il fallait faire
de travaux importants notamment créé un
ascenseur monte-charge il fallait
insonorisé le bâtiment il fallait
reprendre un certain nombre de
dispositifs électriques mécaniques sur
un plan événementiel
ce qui est extraordinaire dans ce
bâtiment c'est qu'on a la capacité
d'utiliser les salles dans plein de
scénographie différentes comme on a des
volumes circulaire on peut faire des
scènes centrales cétacés modernes
on peut aussi travailler les procès n'y
sommes pour défier les modes mètres des
stands dans des configurations en étoile
pour des salons une inauguration presque
symbolique 5% des événements programmés
en 2020 ont été maintenus dans le monde
de l'événementiel
après deux ans de fermeture le palais
des congrès s'est dévoilée ce jeudi 8
juillet en présence de bruno le maire
-ministre de l'économie
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez la
situation économique française
le retour à la normale s'accélère les
chiffres sont très bons les indicateurs
sont bien orientés sur l'investissement
sur la consommation sur le moral des
entrepreneurs
donc je pense simplement que nous tenons
le bon bout et des rendez vous sont déjà
programmées dès le mois d'octobre le
gestionnaire vis près de 190 événement
annuel
que ce soit des congrès des salons ou
encore des rendez vous culturels
on reste dans la cité royale la ville en
partenariat avec la collection
versailles open-air organise jusqu'à fin
septembre des guinguettes
un événement qui regroupe des jeux des
concerts et des fous trucks miquel et
demi d'euros s'est glissé parmi les
fêtards
[Musique]
elles sont de retour les guinguettes de
versailles rempile pour une deuxième
édition
installé sur 500 mètres carrés derrière
l'ancienne poste de l'avenue de paris
elles peuvent accueillir en plein air
près de 500 personnes à une centaine de
mètres
du château ce qu'on peut faire ici c'est
un véritable lieu de vie donc ce qu'on
peut faire ici c'est venir déjà entre
amis en famille ou même salle et c'est
profiter d'un bar dans food truck d'un
espace s'il est bien sûr d'une piste de
danse qui est maintenant disponible
ce projet festif a été imaginé par le
collectif au pnr en partenariat avec la
ville de versailles
l'objectif c'est de répondre en fait à
la demande que les jeunes nous ont
exprimé depuis maintenant vraiment un
bout de temps qu'ils aient un espace un
peu de liberté un peu libre et en même
temps totalement totalement sécurisé
hall en plus voilà faire la fête malgré
les restes le malgré les restrictions
sanitaires
l'événement permet de mettre en avant
des commerçants locaux des dizaines
d'artistes du secteur peut également se
produire cet été devant un public ses
portes étaient trop bien versailles
c'est pas non plus une ville qui bouge
énormément et du coup c'est vrai que ces
endroits là fait bouger beaucoup et
c'est hyper bien avoir la chance d'être
sur scène ce dimanche 4 juillet le
cocktail musique locale et des tentes a
l'air de séduire
ils étaient plusieurs dizaines à venir
passer du temps dans cette guinguette
malgré des conditions climatiques
aléatoires gère versailles ces petits
donc tout le monde se connaît donc c'est
sympa tu va croiser des groupes n'étant
pas vus depuis six mois un an
la musique elle est bonne et voilà c'est
pour ça qu'on aime bien c'est convivial
ya un petit monde est la famille à les
enfants les ados trouvent quelque part
les guinguettes de versets sont ouverts
tous les week-ends jusqu'au 26 septembre
et qu'une pause pendant les premières
semaines du mois d'août
l'entrée est libre
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité demain vendredi vous
avez rendez vous avec l'émission cette
ut week-end excellente occasion par de
l'actualité des loisirs de terminer la
semaine dans les yvelines quand à nous
pour le journal on se retrouve dès lundi
pour une nouvelle édition d'information
locale belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]